what's up guys uh
um damn oh so
i wanted to uh i wanted to just read
some of the comments
on uh some king and the sting episodes
and um yeah because some of it just
makes me laugh man so i don't get i
don't do it
all the time but i try to get in the
chat rooms during the taping or during
the live
um but yeah some of this [__] man so i
just popped open this episode
most recent uh called the people's court
number 107
and i'm gonna read a few here so um
[Music]
sorry theo looks like the kid that just
shows up to summer school just to see
what's going
on so that's pretty true man i would
show up to summer school just
because i'd probably be lonesome at home
and i'd want to you know just at least
be able to be
around people that are pretty much
obviously troublemakers so
um you know benjamin franklin isn't in
summer school
let's be honest bro and that's core
creations made that comment
um
let me see
theo looks like a sous chef at a women's
prison
damn dog that is freaking dicey sun
and ra and accurate so yeah theo do look
like a soup chef at a women's prison you
know oh yeah they need um
oh 86 uh the salmon
please and look these [__] want some
more pineapple at table six
okay these [__] want some more
pineapple
um let me see anything else in here
uh
theo looks like he collects fleshlights
and believe they hold
value i could see that baby like them
pokemon cards
and that's v q naik 9103
and that previous comment was uh james
richmond
um theo looks like every owner of a
recycling center
but all they recycle is their jeans with
their cousins
so you know that oh that's good man
that's good
um
let me see
theo looks like he sells liger liger
i don't want to be racial here pups on
craigslist
so that is uh i could see that boy
i'd vend that l baby that newborn you
know growling bark baby growling bark
so theo looks like he has the largest
supply of wwe action figures
and claims it's for children in need
[Laughter]
man that's good that's uh brandon
ritchie richie
um theo looking like the kid that gets
picked up
picked up last in polar express
uh i don't know who they let me look
that kid up uh i just
guessed that it's right
um theo looks like he catches catfish
pets them and then releases them huh oh
you're gonna be fine boo boo
you i know that water's cold baby gonna
be fine little lady
get out there uh
[Music]
let me see theo looks like the guy at
racing events that spills beer on people
and then tells them to watch
where they're going
man that's good man damn that's from
gavin
meek oh that's good
yeah hey man watch it you know
hey man watch it
uh let me see theo looks like a
character you meet on a side mission in
grand theft
auto i guess or grand theft atlanta i'm
not sure
i think both of them actually are pretty
accurate um
brendan looks like the lead singer of of
a band called
uber eats that [__] is good
uh
theo looks like he's he has got
theo looks like he has six blurry
selfies
stored on his jewel
because some of the jewels they double
as that uh
usb man so yeah damn that's good man
uh theo looks like he smokes bath salts
and thinks it's a shower replacement
oh clean as a whistle
um let me think
this one made me laugh brendan looks
like the guy in special ed classes that
shouldn't be there
but really should fax
uh
let me think
why do they both look like undercover
loss prevention
agents at a walmart in pensacola florida
damn dude
oh my god that's hilarious could you
imagine
being a lost prevention agent
at a walmart oh my god
i don't even think i could handle that
man oh that would be such a crazy job
you know like man look i understand
that the marvin the martian neck brace
didn't fit okay but for you to just
discard it like that in the aisle and
not put it back on the shelf honey i
mean that's just
it's unnecessary um
so what else see if there's anything
good oh and that was by uh
sorry i'm forgetting that was by rockin
robin
and then um
let me see another one was by um
um kenny way
some type of wii
all right uh let me get one more out of
here
theo looking like a kid that just
finished it
theo sorry man
theo looking like a kid that just
finished finished his shift
in a peruvian salt mime
oh you want cracked pepper oh you won't
crack salt
oh you won't just crack uh that's
hilarious man
um yeah and that is by
nor east outdoors so
but anyway yeah man thank you guys for
making me laugh at myself some
uh i had a fun day i just went looking
at a house i'm trying to look for a home
you know and keeping my place in la not
moving or nothing like that but just
kind of shopping around
uh what else is going on that's it